bonjour résumé les bourgeons aubertin
roger bonjour à tous les auditeurs et
merci de nous recevoir à martinez
première secrétaire général du snuipp
fsu donc le syndicat national unitaire
des instituteurs professeurs des écoles
et psg c'est donc voilà on va évidemment
parler de cette rentrée scolaire
régine bébé alors finalement elle a bien
eu lieu cette rentrée est sans sans être
apparemment catastrophique 1 alors avec
ces quelques jours de recul maintenant
une semaine après dites-vous qu'il
fallait bien la faire en temps et en
heure malgré l'épidémie de coronavirus
écoutez nous avions pensé qu'une rentrée
mieux préparés avec avec plus de temps
avec toutes les équipes que ce serait
mieux
la rentrée se passe bien parce que bon
on veut bien dire que ça se passe bien
il ya des endroits où les écoles sont
obligés de fermer ou en tout cas on va
dire pas trop mal avec la volonté de
tous et puis parce que bon bien on sait
bien ce que c'est que qu'une rentrée et
c'est bien parce qu'on connaît les
enjeux d'une rentrée s'il vraiment le
début d'une des activités c'est la prise
pour certains leur première année
d'école dont vous pensez bien que ça
doit être bien préparé on devra lancer
des élèves dans en confiance voilà et
nous ne sentons pas que nous avions eu
suffisamment de temps pour préparer les
petits et les grands
après la période de confinement on en a
jamais parlé
quel est l'impact sur les élèves là
aussi ça permet quand on a le temps de
discuter quand on a le temps de préparer
on se dit voilà à avant d'entamer sur
les chapeaux de roue et bien voilà il
faut il faudrait mettre en place
certains ateliers de discussion déjà
pour vous c'est une rentrée scolaire qui
s'est fait tout de même quelque peu à
marche forcée forcément parce que c'est
dans l'air du temps il faut faire les
choses il faut y aller
et puis voilà ça c'est forcément faire à
marche forcée on ne nous écoute pas 1
il faut faire la rentrée de manière
naturelle comme si voilà le plus
naturellement possible on va dire mais
aussi on sait qu'il ya des conditions
sanitaires donc vous
vous en bon soldat en missionnaires de
la république pour l'éducation nationale
finalement vous vous y êtes allé alors
nous ne voulions pas prendre de bons
soldats au moins bon au moins pour les
élèves pour leur enseigner donc
l'acronyme à suippes je le disais c'est
pour les instituteurs professeurs des
écoles et psg ces pgc ses professeurs
d'enseignement général de collège
alors justement ça a été plus facile
dans les collèges que dans les écoles
primaires est ce que c'est à peu près la
même chose comment comme alors d'évaluer
le collège elle a quand même l'avantagé
de pouvoir
échelonné sa rentrée à nous d'accord
c'était une d1 voulait faire une
analogie on aurait beau si procéder
comme ça
donc y'a plus il ya eu un peu plus de
temps dans les collèges pour faire cette
rentrée on estime quand même que les
élèves ont pu être mieux pris en charge
de cette manière-là que nous qui avons
eu tous les élèves d'un on va dire d'un
couple sur deux jours on a accueilli
tout le monde sur deux jours alors
précisément avez vous d'ores et déjà
recensé quelques premières difficultés
alors soit ponctuel mais peut-être
certaines qui pourrait même se poser au
quotidien
tout au long de l'année surtout tout au
long de on espère qu'elle sera pas très
longue de cette épidémie pour pour les
communautés scolaires un jeu en tentant
les élèves que les enseignants voire
même les parents d'élèves
oui alors l'une des difficultés que l'on
peut relever d'entrée de jeu c'est
l'accueil des élèves et aussi la sortie
des élèves sans attroupement alors ça
veut dire qu'il faut pouvoir aussi
échelonné ça veut dire que il faut
éviter les croisements et ça c'est
vraiment pas évident parce que c'est un
petit peu difficile pour les parents de
ne pas pouvoir entrer dans les classes
d'entrer dans l'école accompagné leurs
enfants donc l'accueil et là ça
mériterait de sa mairie très organisée
et puis bon pain ya quand même
séparation en est un partenaire dont je
parle de la maternelle on est fière
quand même séparation entre le parent et
l'enfant qui ont dit vous pouvez pas
rentrer dans l'établissement
ça fait un peu non il a aussi il faut
assouplir il faut comprendre et être
encore plus vigilant sur sur les mesures
de sécurité donc il faut forcément du gr
forcément la température donc ça prend
énormément de temps
d'accord y compris du temps sur des
apprentissages alors de manière pratique
vous vous seriez prête a préconisé qu'il
y ait des petits groupes quand même
qu'ils puissent rentrer avec des
distanciation vous vous trouvez que
l'interdiction totale comme ça c'est un
peu abrupte brusque poussée très abrupte
et psychologiquement même même l'entrée
en collège
un enfant qui sort de cm2 qui va faire
son entrée au collège etc à qui vous dit
non je peux pas ta compagne et je n'ai
pas le droit d'accompagner sa aussi un
donc vous préconisez des modifications à
ce niveau là est ce que non mais je suis
ami médicaux les médecins tout ça mais
enfin j'imagine que c'est je comprends
bien en quoi on comprend bien la
difficulté on sait bien que nous sommes
tous responsables la santé donc
finalement là on se plie on se plie à
cette règle mais mais c'est vrai que
c'est c'est inconfortable
et si c'est un confort là qu'il faut
gérer après au sein de la famille et
même au sein des équipes pédagogiques
alors parlons du plan de continuité
pédagogique
alors c'est un mot un peu compliqué un
peu savant pour parler en fait peut-être
alors vous allez me dire que je me
trompe moi j'ai l'impression qu'on parle
tout simplement de rattrapages de cours
rattrapage de ben oui le niveau
puisqu'il ya eu le confinement
mais il ya eu chez nous les grèves la
grève qui a duré quand même quelques
mois donc on le sait l'année scolaire
2019 2020 a été quand même sérieusement
tronquée donc qu'est ce que vous en
dites c'est un autre cas dire l'état
hosni est fait sur le plan de continuité
pédagogique
alors la continuité pédagogique était
mise en place pendant la période de
confinement où il fallait prendre en
charge les élèves à distance le
rattrapage c'est autre chose
le rattrapage ce sont des gens
supplémentaires qui sont alloués qui
devrait être allouée est ce qu'ils sont
prévues dans l'académie pour justement
permettre aux élèves de se remettre à
niveau
voilà maintenant c'est dans l'académie
on a prévu au niveau du rectorat le plan
min
bon il faudra encore que ça a été fait
dans une sorte de concertation mais
voilà on nous annonce un volume d'heures
que nous n'avons pas mais qui va falloir
trouver et ça vous est presque imposé la
continuité pédagogique s'organise avec
les personnels d'accord ça ne vient pas
forcèment ne doit pas venir d'en haut
c'est à dire que nous avons nos élèves
nous allons les prendre en charge
évaluer le niveau de départ et pour les
amener où ils doivent être
alors justement c'est votre nouvelle le
nouveau cheval de bataille peut être
cette affaire d'évaluation national
standardisé qui fait partie d'ailleurs
dû de ce plan de continuité pédagogique
enfin cesser inclus c'est effectivement
un des outils sur lequel s'appuient
alors vous vous êtes contre elle compte
ces évaluations nationales standardisés
votre syndicat le snuipp fsu a même
lancé une pétition là il ya quelques
jours à ce sujet pourquoi on pourrait
vous dire mais de qui se moque t'on on
se moque de qui des élèves
on leur propose de faire des évaluations
les actes en elles mêmes que celles de
l'année dernière alors qu'ils n'ont pas
eu le même volume d'heures non il ya le
temps de les prendre en charge leur
redonner confiance
on n'en parle pas un élève a besoin
d'être en confiance pour apprendre et
donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes
là encore c'est un peu de la marche
forcée que les autres voilà que le
ministère montrent que ça fonctionne aux
actions non mais c'est exactement ça on
est dans le show on est dans voilà il
faut montrer que ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne à marche forcée alors c'est
pas notre mode de fonctionnement
on ne fait pas des évaluations à marche
forcée avec des élèves on n'a pas besoin
de voir des f pleurer il pleurait déjà
l'année dernière devant des exercices
qui n'arrivait pas à faire non ça n'est
pas notre notre vision de la pédagogie
ni même du rattrapage alors dans le plan
de continuité pédagogique
il y à aussi bien sûr une référence au
recours de plus en plus fréquent au
numérique
ça y est ça ça c'était déjà le cas mais
avec avec les circonstances l'école est
devenue effectivement ces laïcs écoles
lee enseignement alors est il est vrai
que nous entendons nous sommes en plein
dans l'ère du numérique et c'est aussi
le monde des élèves d'aujourd'hui et ce
sera le monde des élèves de demain mais
le numérique ne pourra pas remplacer le
contact avec le professeur bien sûr il
c'est un support c'est une aide
supplémentaire mais ce n'est pas la base
un élève a besoin de contacts et il faut
pas le minorer nous aurions aimé
effectivement qu'il était prévu dans
notre dans la continuité pédagogique un
hybride voilà on peut faire on va faire
le présentiel sont totalement lâché le
numérique et ne pas attendre d'être dans
une situation délicate pour reprendre le
numérique
mais encore l'associé de façon à ce que
ce soit beaucoup plus fluide qui ait pas
de rupture comme on a connu parce que
c'était une rupture ce qu'on a connu en
mars et et reprendre ça c'était une
rupture et s'assied ça c'est la faute de
personne à présent gérer 8 mai nous
sommes en zone rouge
d'accord rougeau sanitaire voulait dire
alors est-ce qu'on va encore attendre
d'être précipité dans une dans la
continuité pédagogique sans préparation
faire parer au plus pressé
non nous aurions aimé que ce soit clair
sur le papier voilà voilà les conditions
voilà le matériel etc nous reste quatre
minutes avant de parler des effectifs et
des affectations
un mot sur ligne les inégalités
scolaires certains
organisme disque avec cette crise
finalement ça c'est encore un peu à
accentuer un finalement ce sont les les
enfants les élèves des milieux les plus
défavorisés qui finalement on a encore
le plus souffert vous avez constaté ça
vous dans vos écoles sur le terrain de
l'as pas facile nous l'avons constaté
depuis le confinement et nous ne sommes
quand même déçu de voir que les charges
l'état n'ait pas pris la mesure de ces
difficultés là et permettre aux familles
de continuer à distance de continuer de
mettre en place un service ça a été
prévu finalement ça s'est mis en place
et ça a été abandonnée mais ce soutien
là de l'état il aurait été aussi
possible par par le service à distance
qui est le cned un justement en
permettant familles d'y avoir accès
puisque là c'est du papier
1 on sait que tous ceux qui ont des
difficultés n'ont pas accès au numérique
alors que rennes récurrentes aussi enfin
moi j'essaie de termes que j'utilise
avec l'académie le rectorat sur les
effectifs les effectifs enseignants et
donc soit la baisse si on regarde du
point de vue des syndicats où le recteur
qui dit que ça se maintient plus ou
moins je parle du nombre de postes
d'enseignants dans l'académie de
martinique alors selon votre point de
vue ou celui du recteur en place où en
est-on donc à l'orée de cette nouvelle
année scolaire
si spécial alors vous savez que nous
sommes battus l'année dernière puisqu'il
pas de suppression de poste du tout dans
l'académie oui vous avez pu obtenir
certains nombre de choses
alors quand même rester vigilant parce
qu'il s'agit pas de nous les remettre
l'année prochaine parce que ça se fait
aussi de dire ok vous avez une année de
bâton mais l'année prochaine mais comme
il faut rendre il faut rendre nous avons
quand même c'est vrai une baisse
démographique mais la baisse
démographique fait qu'on se retrouve
avec des élèves de plusieurs niveaux
dans une même classe
la difficulté n'est pas moindre quand
vous avez forcément recoupé des élèves
de petite section de moyens de cp pas
dissipées
cm1 cm2 que vous devez faire des
regroupements de niveau vous avez une
difficulté même lorsqu'on a des
effectifs réduits
la difficulté demeure le temps qu'il
faut un élève pour apprendre reste
d'accord
et ça ça passe ça ça n'est pas mesurée
parce qu'on parle de chiffres on parle
de nombre on parle pas d'enfants ayant
besoin de temps pour apprendre ça ce
serait ce qui nous gênerait dans la dans
la vision chiffré de de la politique
académique
alors on termine avec le le problème
récurrent là aussi dites vous de retard
des affectations ça perdure et ça pose
problème et difficultés mais énorme
vivant ce qui était énorme
alors vous préparer votre rentrée dans
le vide mais en fin de compte vous
pouvez pas vraiment la préparer parce
que vous ne savez pas vous êtes affecté
du jour au lendemain on peut veut dire
mais finalement c'est pas là que vous
êtes il va falloir aller ailleurs ça
nous considérons que c'est un mépris
vis-à-vis du personnel que ça assez duré
et qui s'il ya vraiment on veut préparer
on veut mettre les enfants en confiance
et mais il faut commencer par mettre en
confiance et enseignants ce qui n'est
pas le cas cette année encore une fois
une dernière question il n'y a pas de
grève à l'horizon a priori parce qu'on
entendait hier quelques parents d'élèves
s'exprimer ils avaient l'air de
davantage redouter l' annonce d'une
possible prochaine grève dans le secteur
de l'éducation plutôt que les conditions
dans lesquelles se font là ce fait la
rentrée avec le co vide écoutez il n'y a
pas de grève pour faire des grèves il ya
des grèves pour réclamer du mieux pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas mais il est
clair que si nous sommes attaqués dans
un endroit que nous réagirons merci
résume bel et jimmy bonne journée